[موسيقى] أجنبية
هي
[موسيقى]
علينا أن نتذكر أن اليهود يصوتون فإن
نسبة المشاركة في الانتخابات الرئاسية
تقدر بحوالي 80 إلى 85
بالمائة مقابل أه حوالي نصف
أه المصوتين وبقية  دولة أه
هذا يعني
أننا اثنان وأه اثنان ونصف بالمائة من
السكان
يشكلون ثلاثة بالمائة من أه الناخبين
نحن أيضًا أه نعيش في بعض الولايات التي
تعتبر دولًا حرجة اليوم على
سبيل المثال
السكان اليهود في جميع أنحاء البلاد
صغيرة بشكل عام خارج كاليفورنيا
والشمال الشرقي ،
لكننا نشكل جزءًا كبيرًا من
الناخبين في
بنسلفانيا ، فلوريدا ، جورجيا
أريزونا وميشيغان ، أعتقد أن المجتمع اليهودي
له تأثير كبير في الانتخابات الرئاسية
من بعض النواحي ، إنها صورة
مصغرة للباقي  يهود الولايات المتحدة
والأشخاص الملونون خارج نيويورك
لديهم الكثير من الخوف
لأنهم ينتظرون في الطابور
ويضعون أنفسهم في الخط الأمامي
لتليفون نيويورك
[موسيقى]
oreign
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
مرحبًا بكم ، نرحب بكم جيدًا لرؤيتكم ،
مرحبًا بكم في
مركز سياحة التراث والثقافة هارلم
جيدًا ، هدفنا هو إعادة تاريخ
هارلم إلى الحياة
[الموسيقى]
عندما تأتي  لإيذاءك تشعر
بالسواد الذي تشعر به ، تشعر بالموسيقى التي تشعر
بها بالطعام ،
تشعر بالرقص الذي تشعر به كأنك
أسود ، تشعر
أنك في مكان يمكنك فيه التعبير عن
نفسك والتعبير عن
سوادك
كمركز ثقافي لـ  السواد هو
ما أعتقد أن هارلم يمثله عام
1943 ، تخيل أن طفلًا صغيرًا يأتي إلى هارلم
وهو من الأصل من لانسينغ
ميشيغان ،
ثم ذهب إلى بوسطن
وغادر بوسطن وأتى إلى هارلم أبدًا ولم يكن
يعلم أنه يومًا ما سيظهر اسمه على
لافتات الشوارع
مالكولم إكس سريع  إلى الأمام سجن 1946
1948 سمع عن إيليا محمد 1957
مرة أخرى هنا في هارلم من 1957 حتى 1963
لدينا واحد من أعظم
القادة الدينيين عندما كان أعظم
قادة الحقوق المدنية في آل.  من وقت
ومن هارلم ، سيردد صدى الكلمات التي
ستنتشر حول العالم
هذه بعض
العناصر الثقافية
التي تنبع من نساء هارلم
[موسيقى]
هذا الرجل هنا بالنسبة لي هو بطل حقيقي
ضحى
بمسيرته من أجل الحب  من الآخرين
[موسيقى]
غراسياس
إيطالي
[موسيقى]